BACHELOR LOST, 24 AND THOSE
FACES DEATH DVDS ROLLED INTO
ONE.
YES.
THINK OF THE DRINKING GAMES.
AND EVERY TIME YOU HEAR BIG GUYS
YOU DRINK, AND EVERY TIME HUNTER
PHASES CAMERA NUDE, YOU REALLY
DRINK.
AND HELL IMAGINE IF YOU DRANK
EVERY TIME HUNTER LIGHTS HIS
CRACK PIPE.
YOUR LIVE WOULD HAVE MORE HOLES
IN IT THAN HIS DEFENSE.
BY ALL MEANS KEEP PUSHING HEARS.
YOU REVEAL YOUR BIAS AND
AMBIVALOUS TO TOWARDS THE REAL
CONCERNS AMERICANS HAVE.
IT IS NOT GOING TO END WELL FOR
YOU.
YOU MAY END UP WORKING FOR CNN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
--
HE LIKE BANNON HE GOES AGAINST
CUR RESTS SOME TIMES HELD BY
BEARS.
SENATOR
CHADWHEN I CAN MOORE.
.
GRANDMOTHER LOVE HIM BECAUSE HIS
JACKET MATCHES THEIR WALLPAPER.
FOX ACROSS AMERICAN HOST.
AND FINALLY HER POINT ARE AS
SHARP AS HER ELBOWS.
FOX NEW CON TRINT DISTRIBUTOR
KATTMPH.
JIMMY BECAUSE YOU WOULD
DISGUSTING JACKET, DO YOU WANT
TO TAKE A PICTURE WHAT HE THIS
DID TO MY WART AFTER IT GOT
REMOVED.
OTHER GOODNESS.
SHOW IT TO ME.
OH, MY GOSH!
>> IT WAS STEVE'S ACTUALLY
PRETTY MEAN KNEE LIKE THE HOST
OF THIS SHOW?
>>.
OH!
YES.
>> YOU GOT SEND TO ME THAT
MORNING.
>> IT IS AMAZING THAT'S ON MY
FINGER.
THIS FINGER.
I COMPANIES SHOW AUDIENCE.
>> WHERE DO GET WART.
OH, MAN!
.
LITTLE PLACE CALLED PARADISE
ISLAND.
SO JIMMY, YOU ARE ACQUAINT THE
THIRSTINESS ARE YOU SEEN MORE
DESPERATE PLOY AND MORE OBVIOUS
PLOY THAN THAT?
>> JANUARY 6TH?
>> YES THIS HILARIOUS.
ONLY PART LAST NINTH YEP JOYED
SHOWING PEOPLE GET ARRESTED
BECAUSE AT LEAST WE SAW REAL
HAND CUFFS FOR THE FIRST TIME
THIS WEEK.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE ALL GOING FEEL
DUMB AOC DID GET HANDCUFFED BY
THE INVISIBLE GUY THAT BIDEN HAS
BEEN SHAKING HAND WITH.
BUT LET ME MAKE UP VERY SERIOUS
POINT IT CAN'T MOVE NEEDLE
POLITICALLY.
IT IS REAMBLY PART OF IT
OBJECTIVE OBSERVERS CALLING
ELECTION STOLEN, DECERTIFICATES
VSZ JAIL TIME EVERY DEMOCRAT
FROM 2016 DOING A LIFE RIGHT
NOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT I AM SAYING THEY
ARE ON TV EVERY NIGHT TELLING
YOU 2020 PEOPLE DESERVE PRISON.
2016 PEOPLE DID HE SERVE PRICES?
HOW ABOUT [BEEP] YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN?
>>.
THE FUNNY THING POLITIC CHANCE
THINK WE ARE SO STUPID IN 2024.
IF REPUBLICAN WIN THEY ARE GOING
SAY THAT THAT'S STOLEN.
THEY ARE GOING PRETEND LIKE
NOTHING THEY SAID SAID NOW
DURINGIAN 6TH MATTER.
DO YOU THINK THE PUBLIC SEES HOW
BIAS THESE HEARINGS ARE.
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE DONE.
PEOPLE KNOW CAPITAL RIOTS WILL
NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
WHAT THEY GOING TO GENETIC
FLICKS STREAMING DEAL GO LIKE
2024 WITH IT.
I MEAN WHAT I SEE DC LIKE STANDS
IN THE MID APPROXIMATELY ROOM
WITH PAPER BAG ON THEIR HEAD.
AND THEIR OWN WORLDS.
I MEAN FOREIGN EXAMPLE NANCY
PELOSI HER OFFICE SAYS, HER
SPOUSE DOES STOCK TRADES.
>> YES.
SHE LIVES IN COMMUNITY PROPERTY
STATE.
SHE OWNS HALF OF THE STOCK.
SO YOU KNOW IT IS YOU KNOW WHAT
I MEAN?
SO THIS IN THEIR BUBBLE KINDS OF
WORLD ASK REST OF THE COUNTRY
SAYING WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THE LET'S MOVER IT ON.
THEY ACTUALLY GENETIC WORK TO DO
LIKE WE ARE GOING TO DO PRIME
TIME.
I MEAN WHAT WAS ON THURSDAY CAT?
>> I HAVE BEEN REWATCHING SUMMER
HOUSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
>> I FEEL BAD FOR YOU.
>> OH WELL.
SCREW YOU KAT.
>> SCOTT ADAMS YOU KNOW HIM.
MADE THIS GREAT POINT HE
BELIEVED THE HOAX HAS REPLACED
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX.
ALSO SAME MAPPING OF IT.
WHERE LIKE THEY KEEP DOING THESE
HEARING OVER AND OVER AGAIN BUT
THEY ARE RECYCLING THE MIND
READING.
THINGS THEY CAN'T SEE BUT THEY
THINK GOING ON IN -- YOU ARE SO
UPSET.
IN I LIKE WOW.
YOU REALLY BELIEVED ME.
HE GLUED TO T HAVE.
THEY CAN'T WAIT FOR EPISODE.
IT WAS ASTOUNDING TO MEET THIS
PERSON.
I DIDN'T KNOW THEY EXISTED.
BECOMING EMOTIONAL THING FOR
THEM.
AND THEY DON'T HEAR THEMSELVES
WE KEEP CHANGING CLAIM OF THE
COMMITTEE.
STARTED HE INSIGHTED THIS RIOT
AND HE SHOULD IT GO TO JAIL FOR
THIS NOW WE ARE TOLL IT IS HIS
WIFE'S FAULT.
AND THEN LAST NIGHT WE JUST HERE
TO MAKE SURE IT DOES NOT HAPPEN
AGAIN.
ONE NICE THING UNDER BIDEN IT
CAN'T HAPPEN AGAIN BECAUSE THERE
NO WAY THAT MANY PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD GAS MONEY TO GET TO DC.
WANTER CLOSING IN ON MELANIA.
>> YOU GOT ANGRY AS I AM EVERY
TIME YOU CONSIDER THAT WE ARE
PAYING FOR THIS?
>> OH.
YES.
I KNOW.
>> YES.
I AM.
BECAUSE -- WELL HOW MANY TIMES
YOU KNOW, CAN YOU SAY LIKE IT
WAS BAD.
I WASN'T THERE.
YOU KNOW LIKE IT WAS BAD.
AND EVEN THE STUFF THAT KNEW
THAT COMES OUT ISN'T REALLY NEW.
IT IS KIND OF STUFF WE ALREADY
DID KNOW.
BIT WHICH I THINK ONLY THING
THAT COULD HELPFUL FOR ANY ONE
WOULD BE WHAT MELANIE.
I THINK WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
FOR ALL PEOPLE GET INTERVIEWED
ON FIRST 48.
YOU KNOW LIKE, WHO KILLED PERSON
THEY ARE LIKE I DID HE IT.
I MEAN.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING.
IF MURDERER.
WHEN YOU LOOK TO WHAT'S HAPPENED
909% WHO WHOEVER WAS THERE
WANDERING IT AROUND.
IT LOOKED LIKE CREW GONE AMUCK.
I KNOW PEOPLE THAT SET THEY WERE
LET IN YOU DON'T HEAR ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT.
THERE WERE PEOPLE THAT WERE
THERE LET IN WALKING AROUND
IN -- NO.
THEY ARE STILL IN JAIL RIGHT
NOW.
ARE YOU SURE THAT'S BIN KINNEY
OR JUST FUR SUITS.
>> IT IS WEIRD BECAUSE REMINDS
OF HALF WATER BUFFALO HATS FROM
FLINSTONES.
YOU KNOW WHAT I